Hóa Háng án đưa lưu giận thông tin từ báo và chám xin nhà emy từ thông bà,
hải quân hoàng giã anh đang xem sếp kiế hoại giận đầu một lím mình của tỉ,
nhằm mở lại hoạt động hàng 2 tự biển thông mốt.
Chỉ dịch dịch dịch chiến khai cơ tổ gia phá thủy lối tự động,
tàu khu chục thay bốm làm và phương tiện không người lãi để bảo vệ tổ thông mại.
Các quan chức khu phòng anh cho biết kiế hoại có thể chiến khai theo như sửa đoạn.
Chúng đoạn đầu tập trung vào ra phát trủy lối bằng thông người tự động từ tổ mệ.
Sức bạn tiếp theo của thế báo của người thổ tổ trường xấu,
qua khu vực bằng lực lượng hải quân.
Thông tin trường xang một số khu vực tả yêu mình thông mốt của thế đã bị giải trủy lối.
Dù vẫn tôn tại hành lăng dí chuyển hạn chế,
chứ tổ thuyền của một số quốc gia.
Eo bền này là tuyến vận chuyển khoảng 2,000 chăm mồn cùng dầu thông cầu.
Nhưng lượng hành đây đã sẵn mạc,
gió tình hình căn thẳng lâu thang tự đông.
Cái thực hiện xuống đợi bùng phát sống Mỹ và yên xưa ra không kỳ văn vào cuối tháng 2,
đúng này đã tương bố hạn chế hoạt động qua eo bền đối với các khu xa bị có lời đối điệt.